Father Jim Kastigar isn't exactly sure what he and his parish did to get on the bad side of town hall, but he's pretty certain that their meeting with the town president was the turning point. His parish is filled with Mexican-Americans, and they had some complaints about the way the local police were treating them. They presented these complaints to the town president at a big meeting in the church and it got pretty heated. The town president got mad at them. They got mad at her. There must have been 500 people there, and they booed. They actually booed the woman.
吉姆·卡斯蒂加神父并不确定他和他的教区究竟做了什么才惹恼了市政厅，但他很肯定，他们与镇长的那次会面是一个转折点。他的教区里住满了墨西哥裔美国人，他们对当地警察对待他们的方式有一些不满。在教堂举行的一次大型会议上，他们向镇长提出了这些不满，现场气氛变得相当紧张。镇长对他们很生气，他们也对她很生气。当时现场肯定有500人，他们发出嘘声。他们竟然对那位女士发出嘘声。
In most towns, that would be the end of it. No big deal. Not in Cicero, Illinois.
在大多数城镇，这事儿也就到此为止了，没什么大不了的。但在伊利诺伊州的西塞罗，情况却并非如此。
Next thing Father Kastigar knew, town hall refused to give the church permit to hold its annual Way of the Cross procession at Easter, a Mexican Catholic tradition they'd held peacefully for seven years. They fought. They got the permit.
卡斯蒂加神父接下来得知，市政厅拒绝给教堂发放复活节年度“十字架苦路”游行的许可证，这是一个他们已经和平举办了七年的墨西哥天主教传统活动。他们据理力争，最终拿到了许可证。
Then came the tamale dispute. The church youth group was going away on a retreat and they needed to raise some money to do it.
接着又发生了“塔马利（玉米粽）纠纷”。教堂的青年团体准备去参加静修，他们需要筹集一些资金。
So they stayed up all night making tamales in the home. And they were out in front of church, selling the tamales, asking for a donation for the youth group retreat. So I'm just, after mass, I'm still vested. Come out in front. As I was greeting people and standing on the front porch of church, a policeman comes up. Says, have to give you a ticket, Father. I said, what for? I was quite surprised, actually. And so the ticket read, "For running a business without a license."
于是他们整晚都在家里制作塔马利。他们在教堂前面卖塔马利，为青年团体的静修募捐。弥撒结束后，我穿着法衣走到教堂前台阶上。当我正在那儿迎接教友时，一名警察走过来对我说：“神父，我得给您开张罚单。”我问：“因为什么？”其实我当时非常惊讶。罚单上写着：“无照经营”。
So I went to court with a lawyer, just a friend. The hearing officer said, "Well, you know, you're right. There's nothing in the ordinance that says this, you need a license. But they clearly meant it to be in the ordinances. But it isn't. So even though it's not there, you're guilty." Then the lawyer that was helping me asked if it would be necessary for a seven year old child selling lemonade on the street in Cicero to have a business license, and the answer was yes.
于是我带着一位律师朋友去了法庭。听证官说：“嗯，你知道，你说得对。条例里确实没有说你需要执照。但他们显然是想把这一条写进条例里的，只是还没写。所以尽管条例里没有这一条，你依然有罪。”接着，协助我的律师问，在西塞罗街头卖柠檬水的七岁小孩是否也需要营业执照，答案是肯定的。
The youth group didn't give up. They decided they wanted to get a business license to sell food, fair and square. This meant hepatitis shots and a TB scan and special training course on food sanitation. They did all that and applied for a license. Just one hour later, they say, an inspector showed up at the church and told them they couldn't get their license until they put in a third sink and some other improvements.
青年团体没有放弃。他们决定正正当当地申请一份食品销售营业执照。这需要接种肝炎疫苗、进行肺结核筛查，以及参加专门的食品卫生培训课程。他们完成了所有这些要求并提交了申请。据他们说，仅过了一小时，一名检查员就出现在教堂，告诉他们除非加装第三个水槽并进行其他改进，否则拿不到执照。
Then there was the parking problem. The public school near the church had always left its lot open on Sunday morning for people to use when they went to mass. That is, until the city cut off access.
接着又出现了停车问题。教堂附近的公立学校周日上午一直把停车场开放给弥撒的教友使用。但后来，市政厅切断了这一通道。
The director of the school, the principal, told me there was an anonymous phone call saying that people were driving through too quickly, very quickly, in the school lot on a Sunday. And my room is right above this parking lot, and I'd never seen anybody drive quickly through it, so I thought that was kind of strange.
学校校长告诉我，有人打匿名电话说，周日有人开车在学校停车场开得太快。我的房间就在停车场上方，但我从未见过有人在里面快开车，所以我认为这很奇怪。
There was another anonymous phone call which said that someone on Sunday morning and bumped into the fence, done damage to the school property. Well, even the principal himself told me, Father, I don't see any damage at all. But you know, can't do anything about it. We have to close the parking. So they closed the lots.
还有一个匿名电话说，有人在周日上午撞到了围栏，损坏了学校财产。嗯，就连校长本人都告诉我：“神父，我根本没看到任何损坏。但你知道，我对此无能为力。我们必须关闭停车场。”于是他们关闭了停车场。
They said the parking lot was not sound, structurally sound, for parking cars. Which seems kind of strange, since it's called a parking lot, and because the teachers park there every day. The garbage trucks, big, heavy garbage trucks go across. It certainly seems that the parking lot is fine.
他们说这个停车场在结构上不适合停车。这听起来有点奇怪，因为它本来就叫停车场，而且老师们每天都把车停在那儿。那些巨大的垃圾车也会开过去。停车场看起来完全没问题。
The city of Cicero insists that it is not targeting the church for political reasons. The timing of these incidents is a coincidence. That the town president, Betty Loren-Maltese, is a Catholic herself, and would never wage war via city inspectors.
西塞罗市坚称，并非出于政治原因针对该教堂。这些事件发生的时间纯属巧合。镇长贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯本人也是天主教徒，绝不会通过城市检查员发动战争。
But longtime residents are skeptical of these kinds of explanations. Leo Satos moved to Cicero when he was a kid.
但长期居住在这里的居民对这类解释持怀疑态度。里奥·萨托斯小时候就搬到了西塞罗。
I can put it to you simple. Hitler had the SS. Communists had the KGB. Cicero has the code enforcement. OK?
我可以简单地告诉你：希特勒有党卫军，共产党有克格勃，西塞罗有法规执行局。懂了吗？
Cicero is like the Twilight Zone. I mean, these are not things that our normal towns in Illinois-- you know, it's not the same in other communities.
西塞罗就像是《阴阳魔界》。我的意思是，这些事情在伊利诺伊州正常的城镇里是不会发生的……你知道，在其他社区情况并非如此。
Ray Hanania was a newspaper reporter who went to work for the town as press secretary for three years.
雷·哈纳尼亚曾是一名报社记者，后来在镇政府担任了三年的新闻秘书。
In other communities, when you get mad at the mayor, you have a dispute with them. You don't go home worrying about whether you're going to get sued, or whether someone's going to come pounding on your door and inspect your house. You have a disagreement. You move on. And even some people end up being friends. In Cicero it's like, you know, you cross the line, that's it.
在其他社区，当你对市长感到不满时，你会和他们产生争执。你回家时不会担心自己会被起诉，也不会担心有人会砸你的门、搜查你的房子。你们有分歧，但事情过去也就过去了，有些人甚至最后还能成为朋友。但在西塞罗，如果你越界了，那你就完了。
Cicero is just different. For most of the twentieth century, there were direct links between town hall and the mob. Most of the twentieth century, town hall didn't hesitate to strong-arm anybody. If city officials decided they didn't like you, you obeyed, you suffered, or you got out of town. And then finally Cicero row that into a fight that it had trouble winning.
西塞罗就是与众不同。在20世纪的大部分时间里，市政厅和黑帮之间有着直接的联系。在20世纪的大部分时间里，市政厅毫不犹豫地恐吓任何人。如果市政官员决定他们不喜欢你，你就必须服从，否则就得忍受痛苦，或者离开这个镇。最后，西塞罗陷入了一场它很难赢的争斗。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Cicero, Illinois. The story of a town in a bubble and what happens when the bubble pops.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的话题是伊利诺伊州的西塞罗。这是一个关于身处“泡沫”中的城镇，以及当泡沫破裂时会发生什么的故事。
And let's say before we go any further that Cicero is just over the border on Chicago's west side. And although officially it is called a suburb, what it actually looks like is just another West Side Chicago neighborhood. Working class families, brick bungalow houses.
在继续深入之前，我们要说明西塞罗就在芝加哥西郊的边界外。虽然官方称其为郊区，但它看起来实际上就像是芝加哥西区的另一个街区。住着工人阶级的家庭，还有砖砌的平房。
For decades, Cicero was this place that did not want outsiders moving in. That fought violently against blacks and other minorities coming from town. And then at some point, the outsiders came anyway.
几十年来，西塞罗一直是一个不欢迎外来者迁入的地方。它曾暴力对抗黑人和其他少数族裔。但到某个时候，外来者还是来了。
In a sense, this story today is a kind of worst case scenario. You have a town connected to the mob, notoriously racist. So what happens when the town starts to go through the kind of demographic changes that are happening everywhere else, all over America? What happens when people of other races start to show up in large numbers?
从某种意义上说，今天这个故事是一个典型的最坏情况。你拥有一个与黑帮勾结、众所周知的种族主义城镇。那么，当这个城镇开始经历美国其他地方都在经历的那种人口结构变化时，会发生什么呢？当其他族裔的人开始大量出现时，会发生什么呢？
Well, what happened in Cicero wasn't just that the town opposed it, kicking and screaming and fighting every step of the way. Though they did. It's a lot more complicated than that.
嗯，西塞罗发生的事情不仅仅是该镇的反对——他们确实在每一步都又踢又闹地抗争——情况比那要复杂得多。
Just a few weeks from now, the first week of April, 2001, the town will hold elections. The same Republican political machine that has run the town for decades faces a Hispanic challenger who the machine is likely to defeat, despite the fact that three-fourths of the town is now Hispanic. Today we explain how that is possible. Stay with us.
就在几周后，即2001年4月的第一周，该镇将举行选举。几十年来统治该镇的同一个共和党政治机器，正面临一位拉美裔挑战者。尽管该镇四分之三的人口现在都是拉美裔，但该机器很可能会击败他。今天，我们将解释这是如何可能的。请继续收听。
I am joined in this very special edition of our program by Alex Kotlowitz, who will be co-hosting the hour. He is the author of the books There Are No Children Here and The Other Side of the River, and he's an occasional contributor to our program. Welcome, Alex.
在这期特别节目中，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨将和我共同主持。他是《这里没有孩子》和《河的另一边》等书的作者，也是我们节目的特约撰稿人。欢迎你，亚历克斯。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
So Alex, our plan here is that sometimes we're going to do these stories together. Sometimes we're going to trade off between us. Why don't you take us into act one?
亚历克斯，我们的计划是，有时我们会一起做这些故事，有时我们会轮流讲述。你带我们进入第一幕好吗？
Sounds good.
好的。
Act One. Untouchables.
第一幕：不可触碰的人。
To understand how Cicero handled an influx of Hispanic outsiders, you have to understand how the town traditionally dealt with conflict. And to understand that-- I know this might sound strange-- we have to talk about Al Capone.
要了解西塞罗是如何处理拉美裔外来者涌入问题的，你必须了解该镇处理冲突的传统方式。而要理解这一点——我知道这听起来很奇怪——我们必须谈谈阿尔·卡彭。
Al Capone moved to Cicero in 1924, when Chicago decided to crack down on the mob. In Cicero, he rigged elections with a combination of violence and kidnapping. He installed and controlled the town president. He owned the police force. He made Cicero into a safe haven for his businesses, which at the time employed hundreds of people.
阿尔·卡彭于1924年搬到西塞罗，当时芝加哥决定打击黑帮。在西塞罗，他通过暴力和绑架相结合的方式操纵选举。他安插并控制了镇长，掌控了警察局。他把西塞罗变成了他生意的避风港，当时雇佣了数百人。
However the outside world might see Al Capone, people in Cicero remember him fondly.
无论外界如何看待阿尔·卡彭，西塞罗的人们对他记忆犹新。
He was all right. We didn't kick him out of Cicero.
他挺好的，我们并没有把他赶出西塞罗。
Here's a lady I met after mass one Sunday at Father Kastigar's church. Sophia Bannick.
这是一位我在卡斯蒂加神父教堂弥撒后遇到的女士，索菲娅·班尼克。
He took care of the poor. I mean, he didn't keep all the money for himself. He'd give out the Thanksgiving baskets, food baskets and that, to the very poor families. And so he helped out a lot of families.
他照顾穷人。我的意思是，他并没有把钱全留给自己。他会给非常贫困的家庭发放感恩节篮子、食品篮之类的东西。所以他帮助了很多家庭。
Here's Christy Berkos, who once was a town lawyer in Cicero, and for a period the town president.
这是克里斯蒂·伯科斯，他曾是西塞罗的镇政府律师，也曾担任过一段时间的镇长。
I do remember Al Capone, way back when. I was probably five or six years old. He'd get in a little gangway right off of Cicero Avenue and Cermak, and all the kids would gather there, and he would throw change in the air, and all the kids would scramble for all the change. He did it quite often.
我确实记得阿尔·卡彭，那是很久以前的事了。那时我大概五六岁。他会待在西塞罗大道和瑟马克路旁的一个小巷子里，所有的孩子都会聚在那里，他会把零钱扔向空中，孩子们就会争抢那些硬币。他经常这样做。
You could be traveling in South America or Europe and people would do the international sign of Cicero. The fingers like machine guns.
你可能在南美洲或欧洲旅行时，人们会对你做出西塞罗的国际手势。手指模仿机关枪的样子。
Rat-a-tat.
嗒嗒嗒。
That's right.
没错。
Again, the town's former press officer, Ray Hanania.
再次请出该镇的前新闻官，雷·哈纳尼亚。
You know, this perception that I would encounter all the time in Cicero was, the mob did a good job of running the city. They cleaned the streets. And when the mob was in control, we got our garbage picked up, our taxes were low, crime was down. No, it was! It was, like, amazing.
你知道，我在西塞罗经常听到的那种看法是，黑帮在管理城市方面做得很好。他们清理街道。当黑帮掌权时，垃圾有人收，税收很低，犯罪率也很低。不，这是真的！这简直太不可思议了。
People would say this? People would actually say this?
人们会这么说？人们真的会这么说？
Yeah. I mean, all the time. And still do.
是的，我的意思是，一直都在说。现在依然如此。
The town's connection to the mob didn't stop with Al Capone. It continued straight through to the present day. In the '90s, the town of Cicero overpaid a mob-connected insurance company $4.5 million. And investigation is still ongoing. In fact, there's been a continuous string of investigations and indictments for decades. Five indictments this year alone, including a few town officials.
该镇与黑帮的联系并没有随着阿尔·卡彭而结束，它一直持续到今天。在90年代，西塞罗镇向一家与黑帮有关联的保险公司多支付了450万美元。调查至今仍在进行。事实上，几十年来一直有一连串的调查和起诉。仅今年就有五项起诉，其中包括几名镇政府官员。
In 1951, Cicero became notorious for something besides Al Capone when an African American family moved to town, a Chicago bus driver named Harvey Clark with his wife and kids. They kicked off a three day riot in which white mobs entered their apartment and destroyed it, pushing a piano through the wall. Police watched but did nothing. The governor had to call out the National Guard.
1951年，西塞罗因为阿尔·卡彭以外的事情而臭名昭著。当时一个非裔美国人家庭搬到了镇上，一位名叫哈维·克拉克的芝加哥公交司机带着妻子和孩子搬了进来。这引发了一场为期三天的骚乱，白人暴徒闯入他们的公寓并将其摧毁，甚至把一架钢琴推穿了墙壁。警察在旁看着却无动于衷。州长不得不召集国民警卫队。
There were other incidents as well. By the '60s, the town was known as the Selma of the north. Of course, lots of towns and neighborhoods in the '50s and '60s tried to keep blacks out, but in Cicero, they succeeded.
此后还发生过其他事件。到60年代，该镇被称为“北方的塞尔玛”。当然，在50年代和60年代，许多城镇和社区都试图将黑人拒之门外，但在西塞罗，他们成功了。
Blacks were allowed in Cicero between six in the morning and six at night. Working hours. After that, you know, you're not welcome anymore.
黑人可以在早上六点到晚上六点之间进入西塞罗。那是工作时间。在那之后，你知道，就不再受欢迎了。
Leo Satos and his brother Victor remember how in the '60s, they and their buddies would be hanging around on the street and police would come by and then send them on little missions.
里奥·萨托斯和他的兄弟维克多记得在60年代，当他们和朋友们在街上闲逛时，警察会过来派遣他们去执行一些小任务。
Oh, sure, many times. I mean, we were just sitting around [UNINTELLIGIBLE] at the tractors, and there's two officers come and say, oh, listen, you guys. There's a black person over-- well, they didn't refer to them as black then. But they'd say, yeah, on 56th and Roosevelt. And it's after six o'clock. And our job was to physically escort them out of town. You know? With rocks, bricks, stones, whatever. You know? And if we didn't, well, we'd end up in jail for illegal gathering or whatever.
噢，当然，很多次。我的意思是，我们只是坐在拖拉机旁边，两名警察走过来说，听着，伙计们。那边有个黑人——嗯，他们那时不把他们称为黑人。但他们会说，在56街和罗斯福路那边。现在已经过了六点了。我们的工作就是把他们物理赶出镇子。你懂吗？用石块、砖头，不管什么东西。你知道吗？如果我们不这么做，我们就得因为非法聚集或其他什么原因进监狱。
Loitering.
流浪罪。
Yeah. And that'd be the end of story.
是的，故事也就那样结束了。
Talking about the black people. We've always had them.
谈到黑人。我们一直都有黑人。
Again, here's Sophia Bannick, one of the Catholic ladies I met after mass.
再次请出我在弥撒后遇到的天主教女士索菲娅·班尼克。
Walking down 14th street. Remember, we had National Malibu. They all worked there. They used to go into our stores and ask the butcher to make them a ham sandwich or something. I have a friend who had a tavern. They used to go and have a drink and cash their checks there. And they walked up and down.
走在第14街。记得吗，我们有“国家马里布”公司，他们都在那儿工作。他们过去常走进我们的商店，让屠夫给他们做火腿三明治什么的。我有个朋友开了家小酒馆。他们常去喝一杯，在那里兑现支票。他们走来走去。
We thought nothing of it. In fact, we'd even say hello and everything else. We were never taught to avoid them or shun them or something.
我们当时觉得没什么。事实上，我们甚至会打招呼什么的。我们从来没被教导要避开他们或回避他们。
Do you think it would have been different if they had moved on the block, though?
你认为如果他们搬到你这条街上，会有什么不同吗？
Well that, yeah, I think so. Yeah.
嗯，那个，是的，我想会有。
In the summer of 1966, Martin Luther King Jr. came to Chicago after his successes in the south and he staged marches in Chicago neighborhoods, that weren't far  from Cicero. But when he threatened to march in Cicero, county officials warned that it would be a "suicide mission." That was the phrase they used.
1966年夏天，马丁·路德·金在南部取得成功后来到芝加哥，并在芝加哥附近的街区组织游行。但当他威胁要在西塞罗游行时，县政府官员警告说这将是一次“自杀任务”。那是他们使用的措辞。
As recently as the 1980s, a federally monitored effort to desegregate Cicero failed to lure black families to town. Around that time, a run-in between a police sergeant and one of the few African Americans who had moved to Cicero resulted in 1980s-era mandatory human relations training for the entire Cicero police force.
直到80年代，一项由联邦监督的在西塞罗消除种族隔离的努力未能吸引黑人家庭来到该镇。大约在那个时候，一名警察警长和搬到西塞罗为数不多的非裔美国人之一发生冲突，结果导致整个西塞罗警察局在80年代接受了强制性的人际关系培训。
Long-time civil rights activist Cal Williams helped organized the session.
长期的民权活动家卡尔·威廉姆斯帮助组织了这次培训。
When we got there, most of the people who came in with blue T-shirts with the lettering "Cicero Police and Proud of It" across them. Except for the sergeant. And he had his own separate T-shirt. And it said, "Police Brutality-- The Fun Part of Police Work." And that was their message to us.
当我们到达那里时，大多数人穿着蓝色T恤，上面写着“西塞罗警察，引以为豪”。除了警长。他有自己的特制T恤，上面写着：“警察暴力——警察工作中快乐的部分”。这就是他们给我们的信息。
So this was the environment the Mexican-Americans moved to when they arrived in Cicero starting in the 1970s. Hostile residents, hostile officials. And this is where our story really begins.
这就是70年代墨西哥裔美国人开始来到西塞罗时所处的环境。充满敌意的居民，充满敌意的官员。而我们的故事也正是从这里开始。
Act Two. The Inevitable.
第二幕：不可避免的。
It was economics that finally integrated Cicero, succeeding where protest marches failed. By the '70s and '80s, old Cicero was disintegrating on its own. Industries shutting down, grown kids moving away, the older generation dying off. Mexican-Americans wanted the houses and realtors needed someone to sell them to.
正是经济因素最终促成了西塞罗的融合，完成了抗议游行未能实现的目标。到了70年代和80年代，旧西塞罗正在瓦解。工业倒闭，长大后的孩子搬走，老一代人去世。墨西哥裔美国人想要这些房子，而房地产商需要把它们卖给谁。
After all the violence when blacks tried to move in, if you ask longtime residents why they felt Mexican-Americans were acceptable neighbors, they often just kind of shrug and reply, well, they weren't black. Having said that, for the first wave of newcomers, things could get pretty rough. This is Frank Aguilera, whose family moved here in the '70s.
在黑人试图搬入时经历了一切暴力之后，如果你问老居民为什么他们觉得墨西哥裔美国人是可以接受的邻居，他们通常只会耸耸肩回答，嗯，他们又不是黑人。话虽如此，对于第一波新来者来说，日子确实可能很难过。这是弗兰克·阿奎莱拉，他的家人在70年代搬到了这里。
First thing they did to my house was burn my garage, killed my dog, and put a swastika on my doorway.
他们对我房子做的第一件事就是烧了我的车库，杀了我的狗，还在我的门口画了一个纳粹万字符。
Killed the dog?
杀了狗？
They poisoned him.
他们毒死了它。
And that was within how soon after--
那是在你搬进……之后多久？
In about a week after we moved to Cicero. About 25 years ago.
大概在我们搬到西塞罗一周后。大约25年前。
Why did you decide to stay?
你为什么决定留下来？
Well, I was a child, so I had no choice.
嗯，我当时还是个孩子，没得选。
Why did your family decide to stay?
为什么你的家人决定留下来？
Well, they liked Cicero. You know, they bought their first home. And it was the American dream, owning their own house.
嗯，他们喜欢西塞罗。你知道，他们买了第一套房子。那是美国梦，拥有属于自己的房子。
1980. Just a fraction of the town was Hispanic. By 1990, it was a third of Cicero. In the 2000 census, Hispanic residents make up 77% of the town. Drive on Cermak Road and when you see today is a clean, prospering community whose businesses are mostly Mexican. Groceries and banquet halls and banks, with just a handful of aging storefronts that say things like "Dumpling Capital of USA."
1980年，拉美裔在镇上只占极少数。到1990年，他们已经占到西塞罗人口的三分之一。在2000年的人口普查中，拉美裔居民占了全镇的77%。开车经过瑟马克路，今天你看到的是一个干净、繁荣的社区，其企业大多是墨西哥人开的。有杂货店、宴会厅和银行，只有少数几家老旧的店面写着类似“美国饺子之都”之类的招牌。
But as this population shift happened, the old guard that ran the town did everything possible to hold on, which included all sorts of things that no other town anywhere seemed to have ever tried. The person behind most of these efforts was the current president of Cicero, a woman named Betty Loren-Maltese. She's had such a visible profile in Cicero that most everyone there now simply refers to her as "Betty." Here's how she came to power.
但是随着人口结构的转变，管理该镇的旧势力竭尽全力坚守阵地，其中包括各种似乎其他城镇从未尝试过的事情。这些努力背后的关键人物是现任西塞罗镇长，一位名叫贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的女士。她在西塞罗有着极高的知名度，以至于那里的每个人现在都简称她为“贝蒂”。以下是她上台的方式。
She was once married to a city official named Frank Maltese, 19 years her senior, who also apparently worked as a bookie for a mobster with the unhappy name Rocco Infelise. In 1990, Frank Maltese pled guilty to mob-related gambling charges. But he hadn't started to serve his time when the then-town president died. Frank Maltese was the heir apparent, but facing prison time, he had his wife appointed to the job. She had also been working in the city government. He died the same year she took office, in 1993, and she named the town's public safety building after him. We were unable to determine if it is the only government building in Illinois named after a convicted mobster.
她曾经嫁给了一位比她大19岁的市政官员弗兰克·马尔泰斯，他显然也曾为一名绰号不幸叫“罗科·因费利斯”的黑帮成员做博彩代理。1990年，弗兰克·马尔泰斯对与黑帮有关的赌博指控认罪。但他还没开始服刑，当时在任的镇长就去世了。弗兰克·马尔泰斯是当然的继任者，但由于面临监禁，他让妻子担任了该职位。她之前也一直在市政府工作。在他上任的同一年，也就是1993年，他去世了，她以他的名字命名了该镇的公共安全大楼。我们无法确认这是否是伊利诺伊州唯一一座以被定罪的黑帮分子命名的大楼。
The white constituents of Cicero feared that having Mexican-Americans in town meant Hispanic gangs were coming to town. And in fact, in some neighborhoods, there some new gang activity. Betty Loren-Maltese put in place a series of ordinances that was so aggressive that in fact they were were found to violate the United States Constitution. First there was a measure to limit the number of people who could live in any one residence, apparently aimed at big Hispanic families. Then a measure that would seize the cars of suspected gang members and one that would evict gang members from town. The city start suing the parents of kids who were in gangs.
西塞罗的白人选民担心墨西哥裔美国人的到来意味着拉美裔帮派进入了城镇。事实上，在一些社区，确实出现了一些新的帮派活动。贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯实施了一系列极其激进的法令，甚至被裁定违反了美国宪法。首先是一项限制在任何单一住宅中居住人数的措施，显然是针对大家庭的拉美裔。然后是一项扣押涉嫌帮派成员车辆的措施，以及一项将帮派成员逐出城镇的措施。该市开始起诉那些有孩子参加帮派的父母。
Ray Hanania worked for Betty Loren-Maltese starting in 1993 and described the kind of debates that would surround these ordinances.
雷·哈纳尼亚从1993年开始为贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯工作，他描述了围绕这些法令的争论。
One of the ideas we came up with was when you arrest a street gang member, put them to some public use. Make them sweep the streets. Make them clean windows. Make them scour the graffiti off the garage doors. It seemed like a great idea.
我们想出的主意之一是，当你逮捕一名街头帮派成员时，让他们从事某种公共用途。让他们清扫街道，让他们擦窗户，让他们把车库门上的涂鸦刷掉。这听起来是个好主意。
And Betty just needed to take it one step further. She wanted to make them wear a pink apron. And the logic was good. I mean, when you think about the logic-- she wanted to embarrass. She knew that the power of street gangs wasn't just being a member. It was the peer pressure and intimidation. So put a pink apron on them and let your tough friends see you sweeping the curbs.
而贝蒂只是需要更进一步。她想让他们穿上粉红色的围裙。逻辑是成立的。我的意思是，当你思考这个逻辑时——她想让人难堪。她知道街头帮派的力量不仅仅在于成员本身，还在于同辈压力和恐吓。所以给他们穿上粉红围裙，让你那些强硬的朋友看到你在清扫路缘。
It wasn't exactly a good idea, because I remember it went into the board meeting, and I know a lot of us argued against it. But again, you know, she has a way of prevailing over everything in Cicero.
这并不是一个好主意，因为我记得当时在董事会会议上讨论时，我们很多人都反对。但话说回来，你知道，她在西塞罗有一种压倒一切的能力。
One of the candidates running against her brought a pink apron to town hall just before the election and said, yeah, I like the idea of the pink apron. Let's start with your husband, who is a street gang member, too. And just kind of the whole town board meeting just kind of erupted into pandemonium. Everybody yelling, and this pink apron being waved in the air, and Betty screaming at the guy, and the guy screaming at her, and you know, the police intervening-- it was just a mini 1968 Chicago Democratic riot.
一位竞选对手在选举前带着一条粉红围裙来到市政厅，说，是的，我喜欢粉红围裙的主意。咱们先从你丈夫开始吧，他也是个街头帮派成员。整个镇董事会会议陷入了混乱。每个人都在尖叫，粉红围裙在空中挥舞，贝蒂对那个家伙大喊大叫，那个人也对她尖叫，你知道，警察介入了——这简直就是1968年芝加哥民主党骚乱的迷你版。
In putting together today's radio program, we tried a number of times to get an interview with Betty Loren-Maltese, but were always turned down by her spokesman, Dave Donohue.
在制作今天的广播节目时，我们多次试图采访贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯，但都被她的发言人戴夫·多诺霍拒绝了。
Generally as a rule, she just doesn't give interviews.
通常情况下，她是不接受采访的。
Is she giving any interviews during the campaign? I mean, she's running for--
她在竞选期间接受采访吗？我是说，她正在竞选……
Not so far.
到目前为止还没有。
We asked for a copy of her schedule. Maybe we could watch her at a fundraiser or meeting with the town committee. No, we were told. They don't give out her schedule because of threats on our life.
我们要求查看她的日程表。也许我们可以观察她参加筹款活动或与镇委员会开会。不，我们被拒绝了。他们说因为生命受到威胁，所以不能提供她的行程。
Over the last four years, she's had so many different ordinances and civil lawsuits filed against gangs that they've become very angry, and they've taken it out on her in terms of threats against her and her family.
在过去的四年里，她针对帮派制定了这么多不同的法令并提起了这么多民事诉讼，以至于他们变得非常愤怒，并以对她及家人的威胁来报复她。
When is the last time-- how often does that happen?
上一次……这种情况发生得有多频繁？
I don't really talk to the police chief about it much. He takes it all in. And a lot of it has been turned over to the Attorney General and the State's Attorney, as well.
我不太和警察局长谈论这件事。他都在处理。而且很多案子也已经交给了总检察长和州检察官。
So we checked with the Attorney General and State's Attorney and they told us in fact, no one's reported any threats on her life. Which brings us to the real reason she doesn't do interviews.
所以我们咨询了总检察长和州检察官，他们告诉我们，事实上，根本没有人举报过任何针对她生命的威胁。这就引出了她不接受采访的真正原因。
She's got a 99% name ID rate in this town, and like a 70% approval rate. She doesn't really enjoy the media spotlight, and she doesn't need media attention to win her election.
她在镇上的知名度高达99%，支持率高达70%左右。她其实并不享受媒体的聚光灯，也不需要媒体关注来赢得选举。
Under Betty Loren-Maltese, Cicero cops would stop Mexican-Americans for ordinary traffic violations and demand to see their green cards. Town hall ordered a bank that flew the Mexican flag to lower it. Police broke up a baptism party with tear gas.
在贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的领导下，西塞罗警察会以普通的交通违规为由拦下墨西哥裔美国人，并要求查看他们的绿卡。市政厅下令一家悬挂墨西哥国旗的银行降旗。警察用催泪瓦斯驱散了一场洗礼派对。
When David Niebur moved to town to run the police department in 1998, this is what he found.
当大卫·尼伯1998年搬到镇上管理警察局时，他发现了这一点。
You know, officers were shaking down Hispanics on a regular basis. I learned within just the first couple of days that the quote unquote "Gang Unit" was arresting Hispanics, sometimes 25 to 30 people at a time, and their crime was standing on a corner. There was absolutely no probable cause whatsoever for the arrest of the Hispanics, other than they were Hispanic.
你知道，警官们经常敲诈拉美裔。我在头几天内就了解到，所谓的“帮派小组”正在逮捕拉美裔，有时一次逮捕25到30人，他们的罪名仅仅是站在街角。这些逮捕除了因为他们是拉美裔之外，根本没有任何合理的理由。
Here's Niebur's story. It's a brief one, but that's only because his stay in Cicero was brief. He'd actually been brought in by Maltese to reform the police department, or at least that's what he'd been told.
这是尼伯的故事。这只是一个简短的故事，因为他在西塞罗的停留也很短暂。事实上，他是被马尔泰斯请来改革警察局的，或者至少她是这么告诉他的。
Then came his undoing. He found some evidence suggesting that the towing company that does the town's towing might be selling stolen cars. And he told the FBI. The company, Ram Recovery, also happens to be one of the largest contributors to the town president's campaign fund. Betty Loren-Maltese publicly called Niebur a "nitwit" and fired him after just four months on the job.
接着他的厄运降临了。他发现了一些证据，表明该镇的拖车公司可能在销售被盗车辆，他把这事告诉了FBI。那家公司，“拉姆回收公司”，恰好也是镇长竞选基金最大的捐助者之一。贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯公开称尼伯是“笨蛋”，并在他上任仅四个月后就解雇了他。
The police department shipped Niebur his personal belongings. One item was a statue of a policeman holding the hand of a little boy.
警察局把尼伯的个人物品寄给了他。其中一件是一座警察牵着小男孩手的雕像。
This was all in styrofoam, peanut-type thing wrapping. But the head of the police officer had been twisted off and laid nicely inside with the rest of it.
这些都用泡沫塑料包装着，但那个警察的头被扭断了，被很好地放在剩余部分里。
When we asked Cicero spokesman Dave Donahue why Niebur was fired, he said it wasn't because he was cooperating with the FBI, but because he simply mishandled town documents.
当我们问西塞罗发言人戴夫·多诺霍为什么尼伯被解雇时，他说并不是因为他与FBI合作，而是因为他处理镇政府文件不当。
What David Niebur did, in a misguided attempt to either make himself look better or to ingratiate himself with federal officials, decided to turn over all the original towing records to them without making a copy.
大卫·尼伯在一个错误的尝试中，要么是为了让自己看起来更好，要么是为了讨好联邦官员，决定把所有的原始拖车记录交给他们，而没有备份。
But in a case like that, wouldn't it be a simple matter just to get the Feds to make copies and send them back?
但在那种情况下，让联邦人员制作副本并寄回来不是一件简单的事吗？
It would've been. And the town attorney was going to do that. And he specifically told Niebur, I believe, well, just hold on. We're going to make a copy and then we're going to give it to him. And he, of his own volition, decided to turn over all the original records that could have been copied, and it caused a very serious problem at town administration.
本来是可以的。镇律师也打算这么做。他明确地告诉尼伯，我想，别急。我们要复印一份，然后给他们。但他自作主张决定交出所有本可以复印的原始记录，这导致了镇政府非常严重的问题。
No, but I mean, once the town found out that he had turned over the originals, couldn't they just go to the Feds and say, you know, make us copies and send these back? It doesn't seem like that serious a thing.
不，我是说，一旦镇上发现他交出了原件，他们不能去找联邦人员说，你知道，给我们做个副本，然后把这些寄回来吗？这看起来不是什么严重的事情。
I don't know if they give you back records after they've gotten them. You know, I couldn't tell you that.
我不知道他们在拿到记录后是否会归还。你知道，我无法告诉你。
The towing company, Ram Recovery, was never indicted and has denied any wrongdoing.
那家拖车公司，“拉姆回收公司”，从未被起诉，并否认有任何不当行为。
When I meet with real estate agent Armando Gonzales he tells me a series of horror stories about how the town of Cicero seemed to target his real estate firm with all sorts of rules that they didn't apply to other realtors. Rules that cost him literally hundreds of thousands of dollars. this company went from being the largest real estate firm in town-- 48 sales agents in a huge office space-- to being run out of Cicero, nearly bankrupted.
当我见到房地产经纪人阿曼多·冈萨雷斯时，他向我讲述了一系列恐怖故事，关于西塞罗镇如何似乎利用各种不适用于其他房地产经纪人的规则来针对他的房地产公司。这些规则让他损失了数十万美元。这家公司从镇上最大的房地产公司——拥有48名销售代理和巨大的办公空间——到被赶出西塞罗，几乎破产。
We did not know how to respond to the problem that we had. But agents were having problems with inspections, with us not being able to get compliance. In the room where out there was, we were in trouble with the town.  So people didn't want to give us business anymore.
我们不知道如何应对这个问题。但是代理商在检查方面遇到了问题，由于无法合规，我们陷入了困境。在那个区域，我们被镇上盯上了。所以人们不想再跟我们做生意了。
When Armando Gonzalez to Cicero to court, a judge ruled that in fact he had been treated differently from other firms.
当阿曼多·冈萨雷斯把西塞罗告上法庭时，法官裁定，他确实受到了与其它公司不同的待遇。
So why did town hall single him out with such a punitive treatment? Gonzalez's lawyer suggested it was because he was Mexican-American, and, more than anybody, was building a new wave of low-cost homes for Mexican-Americans. Though town hall was hoping to slow the Hispanic migration to town this way, it doesn't seem like a very effective strategy.
那么市政厅为什么要用这种惩罚性的待遇来针对他呢？冈萨雷斯的律师暗示这是因为他是墨西哥裔美国人，而且比任何人都更积极地为墨西哥裔美国人建造新的低成本住宅。虽然市政厅希望以此减缓拉美裔迁入该镇，但这似乎并不是一个非常有效的策略。
Perhaps he just wasn't doing business the Cicero way. On the witness stand, Gonzalez told the story of how he needed a certain town permit once and was set to meet with one of Betty Loren-Maltese's advisors who told him, he'd get the permit, but he should be sure to take care of Betty. He sent her flowers. Presumably this was not enough caring. Maltese's spokesman, by the way, denies that this happened, and the town is appealing the case.
也许他只是没按“西塞罗方式”做事。在证人席上，冈萨雷斯讲述了他曾需要某项镇政府许可证的故事，他去见贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的一位顾问，对方告诉他，他会得到许可证，但要确保“照顾好贝蒂”。他送了花。想必这“照顾”得还不够。顺便说一句，马尔泰斯的发言人否认了这件事，该镇正在上诉此案。
Whatever the truth is, Gonzalez's problems with the town, like David Niebur's, don't seem to be only about race. And this is part of what makes all this so complicated. At some point, it seems, town hall decided that it didn't matter what race ended up living in Cicero. What mattered is that they played by Cicero rules.
真相如何，冈萨雷斯与该镇的问题，就像大卫·尼伯的问题一样，似乎不仅仅是关于种族。而这正是让这一切变得如此复杂的一部分。在某种程度上，市政厅似乎决定了，谁族裔的人住在西塞罗并不重要，重要的是他们必须遵守西塞罗的规矩。
Those rules, Gonzales says, are remarkably familiar for someone like him, who grew up in Mexico. This town that's made life so hard for Mexican-Americans, he says, actually runs a lot like the old one-party government in Mexico.
冈萨雷斯说，对于像他这样在墨西哥长大的人来说，这些规矩是非常熟悉的。他说，这个让墨西哥裔美国人生活如此艰难的城镇，实际上运行起来很像墨西哥旧时的一党政府。
I mean, it's like a government that shouldn't exist in this country. I don't know why these things keep happening in this town. It seems like somehow they are untouchable. They do whatever they want.
我的意思是，这就像一个不应该存在于这个国家的政府。我不知道为什么这些事情会一直在这个镇上发生。他们看起来好像是不可触碰的。他们想做什么就做什么。
The one difference between the sister of government and the old PRI party that ran Mexico, he says, is that in Mexico, after 70 years, people voted the old guard out. Why that hasn't happened in Cicero in a minute from our own PRI, Public Radio International, when our program continues.
他说，西塞罗政府与管理墨西哥的旧PRI党之间的唯一区别是，在墨西哥，70年后，人们通过投票把旧势力赶下了台。为什么这在西塞罗还没有发生，让我们在《国际公共广播电台》的节目继续后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you all sorts of different stories on that team. But today we're devoting our entire show to a brief history of Cicero, Illinois, which is directly next to Chicago. A town of 85,000, Cicero is. And how Cicero, for decades, tried to keep the world at bay and what happened with the world refused to stay at bay.
这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在节目的大多数周里，我们当然会选择某个主题，为您带来各种不同的故事。但今天我们要把整个节目献给伊利诺伊州西塞罗的简史，它紧挨着芝加哥。西塞罗是一个拥有8.5万人口的城镇。我们要讲述西塞罗几十年来如何试图抵御外界，以及当世界拒绝被抵御时发生了什么。
This special edition of the show today is co-hosted by journalist Alex Kotlowitz. We have arrived at act three of our show.
今天的节目特别版由记者亚历克斯·科特洛维茨共同主持。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. War By Other Means.
第三幕：通过其他手段进行的战争。
So Hispanics were sometimes treated badly by town government. But this is a democracy. Hispanics make up three-fourths of the town's population. How hard could it be to vote out the current administration and vote in somebody of their own?
所以拉美裔有时会受到镇政府的恶劣对待。但这是一个民主国家。拉美裔占了该镇人口的四分之三。要把现任政府选下去，换成他们自己人，这有多难？
That's what Joseph Mario Moreno thought, anyway. He's a county commissioner. He moved to town about a year ago and let it be known he was planning to challenge Betty Loren-Maltese, the town president.
约瑟夫·马里奥·莫雷诺也是这么想的。他是一位县专员。他大约一年前搬到镇上，并明确表示他计划挑战镇长贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯。
Moreno was well-connected. It looked like the first time an Hispanic candidate could win. So town officials introduced a referendum lengthening the residency requirement to run for president from a year to year and a half. This would have kept Moreno out of the race, and it so alarmed a federal judge that he knocked the referendum off the ballot, and then told the town that for the next five years, federal monitors would be sent to Cicero to watch over every election.
莫雷诺根基很深。看起来这是拉美裔候选人第一次有望获胜。于是镇政府官员引入了一项全民公投，将竞选镇长的居住要求从一年延长到一年半。这将把莫雷诺挡在比赛之外，这让一位联邦法官感到震惊，他将该公投从选票中撤下，并告诉该镇，在接下来的五年里，联邦监督员将被派往西塞罗观察每一次选举。
Then on December 15 of last year, Moreno and his wife were coming home from a late night party in Chicago. He claims they were tailed by an unmarked Cicero police car, and as they entered Cicero, they spotted another cruiser parked with its lights off right on the border.
然后，去年12月15日，莫雷诺和妻子从芝加哥的一场深夜聚会上回家。他声称他们被一辆没有标记的西塞罗警车跟踪，当他们进入西塞罗时，他们发现另一辆警车正关着灯停在边界上。
We did both simultaneously say, they're going to stop us. They're waiting for us. I was given field sobriety tests, passed those tests. Four and a half hours later, I found I was charged with a DUI. I asked to take a breathalyzer. I was declined. Police officers indicated to me I "got to do what I was told to do." Quote.
我们俩同时说，他们要拦下我们。他们在等我们。我接受了现场清醒测试，并通过了测试。四个半小时后，我发现我被指控酒驾。我要求进行呼气酒精检测，被拒绝了。警察告诉我，我“必须服从命令”。这是原话。
You know, they claimed that it was a random stop. I drive a black Navigator with MORENO plates. You could smell something foul in that whole incident. I mean, that incident baptized me into Cicero politics.
你知道，他们声称这是一次随机拦截。我开着一辆带有“MORENO”车牌的黑色领航员。在那整起事件中你能闻到一股腐烂的味道。我的意思是，那次事件让我接受了西塞罗政治的洗礼。
This was a smear campaign. Moreno made it easy for opponents. Because of a previous DUI conviction, it's actually illegal for him to drive at night at all. As Betty Loren-Maltes's spokesman Dave Donahue happily points out.
这是一场抹黑运动。莫雷诺让对手很容易得手。由于之前的酒驾定罪，他晚上开车实际上是违法的。正如贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的发言人戴夫·多诺霍高兴地指出的那样。
He said he was framed. But you cannot get framed for driving on a revoked license. Either you were driving on a revoked license or you weren't. And that's why, to this day, he still-- you ask him, were you driving that night? He says he won't answer. He refuses to say.
他说他被陷害了。但你不可能因为在驾照被吊销期间驾驶而被“陷害”。要么你在驾照被吊销期间驾驶，要么你没有。这就是为什么直到今天，他仍然……你问他，那天晚上你在开车吗？他说他不会回答。他拒绝说明。
And that's true. We asked him.
这是真的。我们问过他。
Did I read, is this true, that you weren't supposed to be driving?
我读到的，这是真的吗，你不应该开车？
That's assuming I was driving. That's one of the things we won't discuss because we want to keep them thinking.
那是假设我在开车。这是我们不愿讨论的事情之一，因为我们想让他们保持猜疑。
Just to be clear, under the terms of when you're allowed to drive, was it legal for you to drive at all after 7 PM that night?
明确一点，按照你被允许开车的条款，那天晚上7点以后开车是合法的吗？
Assuming I was driving, absolutely not.
假设我在开车，绝对不合法。
Regardless, the Attorney General didn't see enough in the case to prosecute Moreno.
无论如何，总检察长认为案件证据不足，无法起诉莫雷诺。
And in February, the Maltese campaign tried another tactic which led the local news that night.
而在二月份，马尔泰斯竞选团队尝试了另一种策略，并在当天的新闻中播出。
Political rivals of Cook County Commissioner Joseph Mario Moreno first accused him of beating one of his ex-wives and failing to support their child. Citing 1974 divorce files in which a Diana Moreno claims a Joseph Moreno subjected her to repeated mental cruelty.
库克县专员约瑟夫·马里奥·莫雷诺的政敌最初指控他殴打了一位前妻且未抚养他们的孩子。引用了1974年的离婚卷宗，其中一位黛安娜·莫雷诺声称约瑟夫·莫雷诺对她实施了反复的精神虐待。
We will no longer accept a fallen leader anymore. It is hurting our community. It will hurt our youth. And it will hurt everyone.
我们再也不会接受堕落的领导人了。这正在伤害我们的社区，它会伤害我们的年轻人，它会伤害每一个人。
Problem was, they had the wrong guy. As Moreno told reporters at his own press conference later that day--
问题是，他们找错人了。正如莫雷诺当天晚些时候在他自己的新闻发布会上告诉记者所说的那样——
They're greatly mistaken. That Joseph Moreno in that '74 divorce case is not me.
他们完全错了。那个1974年离婚案中的约瑟夫·莫雷诺不是我。
In the hands of the right candidate, such a blatant and botched attempt at character assassination could be spun into political gold. But Moreno hasn't really capitalized on the opportunities handed him. What's more, Moreno is rather soft on specifics about what he'll do for Cicero. He means a lot more on the big general statements about how it's time to elect an Hispanic.
在合适的候选人手中，这种公然且拙劣的政治暗杀企图可以转化为政治金矿。但莫雷诺并没有真正利用好送上门的机会。更重要的是，莫雷诺对自己将为西塞罗做什么细节非常含糊。他更多地依赖于关于“是时候选举一位拉美裔”的大而空泛的陈述。
When we asked him why he's campaigning for this job, here's what he said.
当我们问他为什么要竞选这个职位时，他是这么说的。
Why am I doing it? I guess I'm the chosen one. I have no idea! It needs to be done. And I think Cicero is long overdue for this change.
为什么我要做这件事？我想我是天选之人。我不知道！这件事必须要做。而且我认为西塞罗进行这种改变已经太久了。
When they started saying, well, we need a change-- the change is too late. It's too late. The change has been in process. The change happened.
当他们开始说，嗯，我们需要改变——这种改变已经太晚了。太晚了。这种改变一直在进行中。改变已经发生了。
Frank Aguilera works for Betty Loren-Maltese. And he says compared to when he first moved to Cicero, things have indefinitely improved.
弗兰克·阿奎莱拉为贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯工作。他说，与他刚搬到西塞罗时相比，情况已经有了无限改善。
This is nothing. I mean, I was jumped many times 25 years ago. And the police looking at me while I'm getting jumped 25 years ago because I'm Mexican.
这不算什么。我的意思是，25年前我被围攻过很多次。25年前，警察看着我被围攻，只是因为我是墨西哥人。
We met Aguilera area back on primary night in February at Betty Loren-Maltese's primary victory party. Yellow balloons everywhere, a buffet of chicken and mashed potatoes. About a third of the room was Hispanic.
我们在二月的初选之夜在贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的初选获胜派对上又见到了阿奎莱拉。到处都是黄色的气球，自助餐里有鸡肉和土豆泥。房间里大约三分之一的人是拉美裔。
At one of the tables were members of the Mexican-American Chamber of Commerce in Cicero. They told me that they debated for a long time who to support in this election, and that it was a close vote between them.  But in the end, they decided on Betty. They like the idea of an Hispanic candidate, but they just felt Moreno wasn't up to the job.
其中一张桌子坐着西塞罗拉美裔商会的成员。他们告诉我，他们为了在这次选举中支持谁争论了很久，他们内部的投票也很接近。但最后，他们决定支持贝蒂。他们喜欢拉美裔候选人的主意，但他们只是觉得莫雷诺无法胜任这份工作。
[? Luiso ?] [? Heller ?] owns a travel agency and is treasurer of the Chamber. He says sure, the police in Cicero could use some sensitivity training. Sure, some things at hand could still be improved. But he likes that Betty Loren-Maltese keeps a tight rein. He likes the clean streets and the crackdown on gangs.
（路易索）埃勒拥有一个旅行社，也是商会的财务主管。他说当然，西塞罗的警察需要一些敏感度培训。当然，手头的一些事情仍然可以改进。但他喜欢贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯保持严格控制的方式。他喜欢干净的街道和对帮派的打击。
You know what? We knew that Cicero was tough, and that is the reason we moved here. When you talk to the Mexican-American homeowners, obviously they like the security that they feel with the current administration, with so many cops. They moved into a town looking for a better way of life, and obviously they moved in because they thought that Cicero, it's more secure than Chicago. You know? I mean I grew up in 26th street, and I know what that is. And I moved into Cicero, because I looked in the area, and it's-- sure, you know, the cops are tough. You know? But really, realistically, that is what I want.
你知道吗？我们知道西塞罗很难混，这就是我们搬到这里的原因。当你和墨西哥裔美国房主交谈时，很明显他们喜欢在现任政府领导下所感受到的安全感，有那么多警察。他们搬进这个城镇是为了寻找更好的生活方式，很明显他们搬进来是因为他们认为西塞罗比芝加哥更安全。你知道吗？我的意思是我在26街长大，我知道那是怎么回事。我搬到西塞罗，因为我看了看这个区域，它是——当然，你知道，警察很强硬。你知道吗？但现实地讲，那正是我想要的。
Betty Loren-Maltese's is campaign slogan is "She's Tough Because She Cares." It's actually this combination of toughness and caring that's new about her politics.
贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的竞选口号是“她强硬因为她关心”。正是这种强硬与关心的结合，才是她政治风格的新奇之处。
At some point in her tenure, it must have become clear that she'd never stay in office if she only responded to the flood of Hispanics with hostile ordinances and punitive policing. To those old-school Cicero tactics, she's added the more modern approach of maintaining power by sharing it, or at least seeming to share it.
在她任职期间的某个时刻，她一定意识到，如果她只以充满敌意的法令、惩罚性的警察手段来应对拉美裔的涌入，她就永远无法留任。对于那些老派的西塞罗手段，她加入了一种更现代的方法，即通过分享权力来维持权力，或者至少看起来是在分享。
And so today in Cicero, there's an odd mix of hostility and accommodation all happening at the same time. She's helped build five schools for the new Hispanic families in town. There are lots of Hispanic faces at town hall. Three of the four town trustees are all Hispanic. Maltese's assistant is Hispanic. And she just announced a minority set-aside program funneling public money to minority-owned businesses. And before she takes the stage at her own victory party, there's this.
所以今天在西塞罗，敌意与包容同时并存，真是不可思议。她帮助为镇上的新拉美裔家庭建造了五所学校。市政厅里有许多拉美裔面孔。四名镇受托人中有三名是拉美裔。马尔泰斯的助理是拉美裔。她还刚刚宣布了一项少数族裔配额计划，将公共资金引入少数族裔拥有的企业。而在她登上自己获胜派对的舞台之前，还有这样一幕。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
Town trustee Ramiro Gonzales gives a speech. He thanks the campaign workers, threatens gangs who supposedly disrupted voting, and concludes with this.
镇受托人拉米罗·冈萨雷斯发表了演讲。他感谢了竞选工作者，威胁了据称扰乱投票的帮派，并以这样的话结尾。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Betty! Gracias.
（讲西班牙语）贝蒂！谢谢。
People yell "Betty" and "Viva." And then there she is. We finally see her in person. Betty Loren-Maltese, looking a bit like Elizabeth Taylor during the John Warner years. Middle aged woman in black pantsuit, heavy black mascara, long eyelashes, a crown of teased, swept-up air. Given the ham-handedness of her attacks on Moreno, she handles the crowd and the press-- there are a half dozen TV cameras present-- like a seasoned political pro.
人们高喊“贝蒂”和“万岁”。然后她出现了。我们终于亲眼见到了她。贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯，看起来有点像约翰·华纳时期的伊丽莎白·泰勒。中年女性穿着黑色裤装，浓重的黑色睫毛膏，长长的睫毛，梳着高耸的头发。考虑到她对莫雷诺攻击的拙劣手法，她应对人群和媒体的方式——现场有半打摄像机——就像一个老练的政治专业人士。
She has a certain charisma. Incredibly, one of the first things she does is actually thank the federal monitors who came to town to keep an eye on her.
她有一种特殊的魅力。令人难以置信的是，她做的第一件事竟然是感谢来到镇上监视她的联邦监督员。
I want to thank the outside agencies, especially the federal monitors who came in. Because I know it was a tedious task for them, and I'm sure they did not want to be here. And I hope they continue to remain with us, because I think they'll see that the problem is not with the Republicans, but--
我要感谢外部机构，特别是进来的联邦监督员。因为我知道这对他们来说是一项繁琐的任务，我确信他们不想在这里。我希望他们继续留在我们身边，因为我认为他们会看到问题不在于共和党人，而是——
Not long after, she reads the day's lopsided voting results to her fellow Republicans.
不久之后，她向共和党同僚宣读了当天悬殊的投票结果。
Republican ballots cast were 7,499. Democrats were 3,798. Well, come on.  I mean, it is a democracy!
共和党选票投了7499张。民主党选票投了3798张。好吧，拜托了。我的意思是，这是一个民主国家！
In the end, twice as many people voted for Maltese in this primary as for all the other candidates in both parties combined. The measure of what a long shot this race is for Moreno will be her Democratic opponent in the general election in April.
最终，这次初选中投给马尔泰斯的票数是所有其他候选人在两个党派中加起来总和的两倍。这场比赛对莫雷诺来说有多大的胜算，取决于她四月份大选中的民主党对手。
Well, if the media wants to leave, we can party. And I'll tell you again, I was never afraid against Mario running. I was afraid of him driving.
嗯，如果媒体想离开，我们就可以开始聚会了。我再告诉你一次，我从不害怕马里奥参选。我只害怕他开车。
Moreno's only chance is if he could bring thousands of new voters out to the polls, something no one in Cicero has ever done. Meanwhile, Betty Loren-Maltese has amassed a million dollars to spend on the campaign. A huge amount. A crazy amount by any standards for an election in a town that you can drive from end to end in just ten minutes.
莫雷诺唯一的机会是他能带出成千上万的新选民，这是西塞罗从未有人做过的事。与此同时，贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯已经筹集了100万美元用于竞选。这是一笔巨款。对于一个开车十分钟就能横穿全镇的城镇选举来说，以任何标准衡量这都是一笔疯狂的数额。
Thank you. And viva Cicero!
谢谢。西塞罗万岁！
Act Four. They Say Our Love is Here to Stay.
第四幕：他们说我们的爱永存。
A town like Cicero, what it produces is insiders and outsiders. And just as some people can become addicted to being on the inside of a system, you can get addicted to the rush of trying to bring the system down. This next story is the story of somebody who got stuck doing that, inadvertently, for a long, long time. Then he tried to get away, but that turned out not to be so easy.
像西塞罗这样的城镇，产生的是内部人和外部人。正如有些人会对身处体制内上瘾一样，你也会对试图摧毁这个体制的快感上瘾。下一个故事是关于一个不知不觉中被困在其中，很长一段时间的人的故事。后来他试图逃离，但结果证明这并不容易。
Alex tells the whole story. A warning to our listeners that there is a possibly questionable word hidden somewhere in this story.
亚历克斯讲述了整个故事。提醒我们的听众，这个故事里可能隐藏着一个值得商榷的词。
This past October, Dave Boyle and his wife Nadine moved back to Cicero after being away for 10 years. "I have unfinished business," he told me.
去年十月，戴夫·博伊尔和他的妻子娜丁在离开10年后搬回了西塞罗。“我还有未完成的事业，”他告诉我。
Let me first, though, fill you in on Dave's first tenure in Cicero. He moved here in 1983 and accidentally stumbled into town politics. Early one morning on his way to a contracting job, Dave drove past Mr. C's, a bikers' bar on the corner. Some guys were standing around outside drinking, and there on the sidewalk lay a biker who had been stabbed to death.
不过，让我先向你介绍戴夫在西塞罗的第一次任期。他于1983年搬到这里，并意外地卷入了镇上的政治。一天清晨，在去施工现场的路上，戴夫开车经过了拐角处的一家摩托车手酒吧“C先生酒吧”。外面站着一些人喝酒，人行道上躺着一名被刺死的摩托车手。
It was shocking. Dave wanted the bar shut down. So he went to see the town's deputy liquor commissioner, who was also a police officer. He was told to back off. Many of the taverns were connected to the mob.
太令人震惊了。戴夫想关掉那家酒吧。于是他去找镇上的副酒类专员，那个人也是一名警察。他被告知要退后。许多酒馆都与黑帮有联系。
And he told me that not only is there nothing I can do about it, but if I did anything about it, not only would they kill you, Boyle, but they might kill me. And that's not going to happen. So you just go away. And even say it that nice.
他告诉我，不仅我对它无能为力，而且如果我真的做了什么，他们不仅会杀了你，博伊尔，他们还可能杀了我。这种情况不会发生。所以你走开。他甚至说得还没那么客气。
So you go to this assistant liquor commissioner, and tells you, if it were me, I probably would say, OK, fine.
所以你去找这个酒类助理专员，他告诉你，如果是我，我可能会说，好吧，没问题。
[INAUDIBLE] or else I'm gone. I just thought-- well, basically, I thought [BLEEP] you. You're not going to-- I'm Dave Boyle. I walk upright and I ask the police officer to the right thing. And he told me, the mob won't let you do it. And I thought, what kind of pussy are you?
（含糊不清）否则我就走人。我只是想——嗯，基本上，我想说“去你的”。你不能——我是戴夫·博伊尔。我站得直，要求警察做正确的事。而他告诉我，黑帮不会让你这么做。我想，你这种怂包算什么？
A word here about Dave Boyle. He's a Vietnam vet and is built like a rugby player. Under different circumstances, Dave might have been a barroom brawler. He's loud, curses lots, likes to brag about what a good fighter he is. In short, the perfect person to take on Cicero. In fact, it's hard to imagine any other kind of person being willing to take on the town.
关于戴夫·博伊尔，在这里说一句。他是越南老兵，身材像个橄榄球运动员。在不同情况下，戴夫可能已经是个酒吧打架高手了。他嗓门大，爱骂人，喜欢吹嘘自己是多么好的战士。简而言之，是挑战西塞罗的完美人选。事实上，很难想象还有其他人愿意挑战这个城镇。
At the time, Cicero still had a whole thriving district full of strip joints and prostitutes and bars that stayed open until 6 AM. Dave fought to get Mr. C's shut down, and then went to the police department, and in his typically belligerent way, ordered them to close down five other bars.
当时，西塞罗仍然有一个繁荣的街区，到处都是脱衣舞厅、妓女和开到凌晨6点的酒吧。戴夫争取关掉“C先生酒吧”，然后去了警察局，以他那标志性的好战方式，命令他们关闭其他五家酒吧。
12 hours later, my garage blew up with my cars and all my tools.
12小时后，我的车库连同我的车和所有的工具一起爆炸了。
You say that it blew up.
你说它爆炸了。
Yeah.  They blew it up.
是的。他们炸了它。
You mean it caught fire?
你是说它着火了？
Yeah. Caught fire. That's what it did. Yeah. It caught fire. It was just a fire. It was a coincidence. It took about 10 minutes to burn the whole thing to the ground, cars and all.
是的。着火了。它就是这样。是的。着火了。那只是一场火灾。这是一个巧合。大火烧了十分钟就把所有东西烧成了灰，车子什么的都毁了。
As you've probably observed about Cicero by this point, it doesn't like to be told what to do. Especially by outsiders. So you can imagine then how angry the town leaders were when Dave and his wife collected enough signatures for a referendum to shut the bars at 2 AM. Then the referendum passed by three to one margin. But nothing happened. The then-town president ignored the vote, which transformed Dave into a kind of minor celebrity, with stories about him in the newspapers and on TV. He was talking with the FBI.
正如你通过这点可能已经观察到的关于西塞罗的情况，它不喜欢被告知该怎么做。尤其是被外人。所以你可以想象当戴夫和他的妻子收集了足够多的签名来发起公投，要求在凌晨2点关闭酒吧时，镇领导有多么愤怒。随后公投以三比一的多数通过了。但什么也没发生。当时的镇长无视了投票，这让戴夫变成了某种小名人，报纸和电视上都有关于他的报道。他在与FBI交谈。
So what might otherwise have been a fairly small matter, the time bars should close, suddenly became quite big. Dave and Nadine soon found a dead snake slung over their front porch railing, and the police harassed Dave, arresting him or threatening to arrest him, some 11 times. It all took over their lives. And it all got to Nadine.
所以原本可能是一个相当小的问题，即酒吧应该在什么时间关闭，突然变得相当大了。戴夫和娜丁很快发现门廊栏杆上挂着一条死蛇，警察骚扰戴夫，逮捕他或威胁要逮捕他，总共大约11次。这一切占据了他们的生活。这一切让娜丁感到绝望。
I didn't talk to my friends anymore because I felt so weird. I felt different than they did. They were having babies and, you know, decorating their houses with Laura Ashley things, and building a--
我不再和朋友们说话了，因为我觉得太奇怪了。我觉得自己和他们不一样。他们都在生孩子，你知道，用劳拉·阿什利的东西装饰房子，建造一个……
[INAUDIBLE] burglar bars.
（含糊不清）防盗栏。
Yeah, cleaning up burglar bars and cleaning up ashes from the garage. It was a completely different life, and the only people who seemed to understand us were reporters, and people from the crime commission and the FBI. And other people from Cicero.
是的，清理防盗栏，从车库里清理灰烬。这完全是另一种生活，唯一似乎理解我们的人是记者，以及来自犯罪委员会和FBI的人。还有西塞罗的其他一些人。
Here's how far it went. Dave made not one, but two bids for local office. But his bluntness and go-it-alone style didn't exactly win him votes. At one point, he posted a sign in the town president's office saying "Future Office of Dave Boyle." He lost both elections.
事情就是这样。戴夫不仅一次，而是两次竞选地方公职。但他的直率和单打独斗的作风并没有为他赢得选票。有一次，他在镇长办公室贴了一个牌子，写着“戴夫·博伊尔的未来办公室”。他两次选举都输了。
After seven years of fighting town hall, Dave and Nadine decided it was time to go. Friends felt they were run out of town. And though Dave says it wasn't the case, it was. They were beaten down, drained, both emotionally and financially. And Nadine, quite frankly, just wanted to get the hell out of there. So they moved to Houston, Texas in 1990.
在与市政厅斗争了七年后，戴夫和娜丁觉得是时候离开了。朋友们觉得他们是被赶出镇子的。虽然戴夫说并非如此，但事实确实如此。他们被打垮了，无论是情感上还是经济上都枯竭了。而娜丁，坦白说，只是想快点离开那里。所以他们在1990年搬到了德克萨斯州的休斯顿。
Fast forward 10 years later. Dave's now a lawyer. He suggests to Nadine that hey, maybe they move back. Nadine balks. So Dave promises Nadine, look. I won't get so involved this time around. They buy a brick bungalow this past October and Dave soon wanders into town hall and sees some old faces.
快进到10年后。戴夫现在是一名律师。他建议娜丁，嘿，也许他们该搬回去。娜丁犹豫了。于是戴夫向娜丁承诺，看吧，这次我不会参与那么深。去年十月，他们买了一栋砖砌平房，戴夫很快溜进了市政厅，看到了几张老面孔。
I was at the town hall. I can't remember the exact date, but I was at the legal department a month, month and a half ago. And I was handing some papers in. And I look to my right, and there I see Tony Accardo. And he looked at me like he'd just seen a ghost. And I said, Mr. Accardo, good morning. And I approached him. I went to shake his hand.
我在市政厅。我不记得具体的日期了，但一个月前，一个半月前，我正在法律部门。我正在递交一些文件。我向右一看，就看到了托尼·阿卡多。他看着我，就像看到鬼一样。我说，阿卡多先生，早上好。我走近他。我去和他握手。
And he was the head of the buildings--?
而他曾是建筑部门的负责人——？
He was the head of the building department. And many of those guys have fallen on hard times here recently. He made the sign of the cross in front of me. You're back! Oh my god! And he made a quick side of the cross. He says, thank god I'm retired. You can't get to me.
他是建筑部门的头儿。那些家伙最近都陷入了困境。他在我面前划了个十字。你回来了！天哪！他快速划了个十字。他说，感谢上帝我已经退休了。你拿我没办法。
Dave notices changes in the town. The strip joints are gone. The bars finally close at 2 AM. Lots of people everywhere speaking Spanish, which he likes.
戴夫注意到镇上的变化。脱衣舞厅不见了，酒吧终于在凌晨2点关门了。到处都是说西班牙语的人，他很喜欢。
But the town, he learns, is still up to its old tricks. When he and Nadine settled on their house, they were asked to sign a document which would give the town the right to search their home for housing code violations any time it wanted.
但他了解到，这个镇仍然在玩老一套。当他和娜丁在房子上达成协议时，他们被要求签署一份文件，该文件赋予镇政府在任何时候搜索其住宅的权利，寻找住房规范违规行为。
They do that every Mexican that buys a house in this town. And well, just look around who's buying a house in this town. They're Mexican people. They don't read English. They got three earners to pay off one mortgage, and they're all going to live in a house. And they're all signing these affidavits that give the police, anybody from town hall, the right to enter their house without notice and without a warrant.
他们对这个镇上买房的每个墨西哥人都这么做。嗯，看看谁在这个镇上买房就知道了。他们是墨西哥人。他们看不懂英语。他们有三个人赚钱来还房贷，他们全都会住在一个房子里。他们都在签署这些赋予警察、市政厅任何人以未经通知和未经搜查令进入其房屋权利的宣誓书。
Dave insisted the town change the wording of this document, which they did that same day. And that got the ball rolling. Soon he got involved in the upcoming elections, working for a candidate who's opposing Betty Loren-Maltese. For Nadine, as you might imagine, it all began to feel familiar.
戴夫坚持要求该镇修改这份文件的措辞，他们当天就照办了。这让事情运转起来。很快他就卷入了即将到来的选举，为一位反对贝蒂·洛伦-马尔泰斯的候选人工作。对于娜丁来说，你可以想象，这一切开始变得似曾相识。
He said it's going to be different this time. I'm a lawyer. None of those same things are going to happen. Don't worry. I won't get involved in politics. I won't run for office, and I certainly won't use our money to do it. And--
他说这次会不一样。我是一名律师。那些同样的事情都不会发生。别担心。我不会参与政治。我不会竞选公职，我也绝对不会用我们的钱去这么做。然后——
I haven't used any of our money! Except what I gave away.
我没动用我们的钱！除了我捐出去的那部分。
So I caved. I did.
所以我妥协了。我确实妥协了。
Well, you've been back now for three months. Has he kept his word?
好吧，你回来已经三个月了。他遵守诺言了吗？
Since October. About not getting--?
从十月开始。关于不卷入……？
About not getting back involved.
关于不再卷入其中。
He hasn't quite kept--
他没完全遵守——
He's a lying mother [BLEEP], isn't he?
他是个撒谎的混蛋，不是吗？
I told him once, when he was starting to get involved with this recent campaign, I said, Dave, I see you going down that whirlpool. It's taking you down again. And he actually pulled back a little bit. He did. Not much, but he did.
我告诉过他一次，当他开始卷入最近的竞选活动时，我说，戴夫，我看着你掉进那个漩涡里。它又在把你往下拉。他确实稍微后退了一点。他确实做到了。没多少，但他做到了。
I asked Dave what his next move is. "I'm going to build an attached garage," he tells me. "No, how about in terms of the town?" I ask. He smiles and says, "That's part of it. I have to apply for a permit," he says. That's his plan. Say bad things about the town president in public and then apply for a permit.
我问戴夫他的下一步计划是什么。“我要建一个附属车库，”他告诉我。“不，你是说关于这个城镇？”我问。他笑了笑说，“那是其中的一部分。我得申请许可证，”他说。这就是他的计划。公开说镇长的坏话，然后申请许可证。
These days one of the most interesting things about Cicero, despite everything we've told you this hour, about town hall antagonizing its own citizens, is this. If you actually walk the neighborhoods and talk to people about how they're getting along with their neighbors, most people seem to be getting along just fine. You hear lots of stories of older white residents who were wary at first, but then warmed up. There's still rough moments, but things seem way more civil, way more friendly than you would expect, given the town's history. Alex put together this story about three neighbors.
这些日子里，关于西塞罗最有趣的一点是，尽管我们这一个小时告诉了你们所有关于市政厅如何与自己的公民作对的事情，但事实是这样的：如果你真的走进街区，和人们谈论他们如何与邻居相处，大多数人似乎相处得很好。你会听到许多老白人居民的故事，他们一开始很谨慎，但后来变得亲近了。仍然有一些艰难的时刻，但事情看起来比你根据该镇的历史所预期的要文明得多、友好得多。亚历克斯整理了这个关于三个邻居的故事。
Here's another way to measure the changes in Cicero. We met a woman named Loretta Rivera who moved to town back in the mid-'80s. She found it to be so hostile to Hispanics that she and her family moved out. Five years later, after more Hispanics had settled in Cicero, she tried again. This time it was easier.
这是衡量西塞罗变化的另一种方式。我们遇到了一位名叫洛蕾塔·里维拉的女士，她在80年代中期搬到镇上。她发现这里对拉美裔充满敌意，于是她和家人搬走了。五年后，在更多的拉美裔在西塞罗定居后，她又试了一次。这一次容易多了。
Loretta told me about two of her neighbors, Annie and Nancy. Both of them white, both of them longtime Cicero residents. She considered one of them to be very accepting, and one not accepting it all. But the reality may be more complicated than that.
洛蕾塔告诉了我关于她的两个邻居，安妮和南希的故事。她们都是白人，都是西塞罗的长期居民。她认为其中一个非常接受，而另一个一点也不接受。但现实可能比这更复杂。
Here's Loretta with one of the women, Annie Ryder, in Annie's kitchen. They're close friends, even though Loretta, now a a second grade teacher, is 40, and Annie, a widow, is 74. Loretta is explaining to Annie what it was like the first time she and her husband Conrado moved to Cicero.
这是洛蕾塔和其中一位女性，安妮·莱德，在安妮的厨房里。她们是亲密的朋友，尽管身为二年级老师的洛蕾塔今年40岁，而安妮是一位74岁的寡妇。洛蕾塔正在向安妮解释她和丈夫康拉多第一次搬到西塞罗时是什么样子。
I told you about when we used to rent on 53rd Court, the Polish guy that almost got into a fight with Conrado. His big problem was that we were parking in front of his house.
我跟你说过我们过去在53法院租房的时候，那个波兰人差点和康拉多打起来的事儿吗？他最大的问题是我们停在他家房子前面。
No, you never told me.
不，你从没跟我说过。
I never told you that? It was Christmas Eve and he was a little tipsy. And he came out screaming at us, telling us, you know, you should go back to your country, why the hell are you here? You shouldn't park in front of my yard. I pay taxes. You don't pay anything. And I remember Conrado, because being so angry-- I mean, I had to literally grab him, because he was going to hit the guy. And I remember Conrado, out of frustration-- he didn't even know what he said. His English was very broken. And I remember him telling him, you Poland, go back to Polish, or something. He said, you even said it wrong! You don't say it that way.
我没跟你说过那个？那是平安夜，他喝得有点醉。他冲出来对我们大喊大叫，告诉我们，你知道，你应该回你的国家去，为什么你要到这儿来？你不应该停在我的院子前面。我纳税，你什么都不付。我记得康拉多，因为非常生气——我的意思是，我不得不从字面上抓住他，因为他要去打那个人。我记得康拉多，出于沮丧——他甚至不知道自己在说什么。他的英语非常结结巴巴。我记得他告诉那个人，“你波兰，滚回波兰”，还是什么的。他说，你甚至说错了！你不该那么说。
And he also, again, blamed us, you know. That that's why Cicero was in such a bad rut, because ever since Mexicans started moving here, we were ruining the town, and blah blah blah.
而且他还再次责怪我们，你知道。这就是为什么西塞罗陷入这种糟糕的困境，因为自从墨西哥人开始搬到这里，我们就毁了这个镇，诸如此类。
This town has been ruined so many times! It's like oh, forget it.
这个镇已经被毁了无数次了！真是的，算了吧。
We usually talk about how the newcomers assimilate to their new environment. But as I listen to Annie and Loretta, I was struck by how it was Annie who assimilated to the newcomers.
我们通常谈论的是新来者如何融入新环境。但当我听安妮和洛蕾塔谈话时，我被安妮如何融入新来者所打动。
Did she tell you we used to walk every morning at 6 o'clock in the morning?
她告诉你我们过去每天早上6点去散步吗？
5:30. There were [UNINTELLIGIBLE] 5:30.
5点半。那是（含糊不清）5点半。
Did you learn any Spanish?
你学西班牙语了吗？
Yo no se.
我不知道。
She learns it and then she forgets it. I remember when we first started walking, remember, we made a deal? Every week I was going to teach you a new word. And then the next day I would ask her and she would go, huh? Ah, forget it! And then we would come and have coffee.
她学了然后又忘了。我记得我们刚开始走路的时候，记得吗，我们达成了一个协议？每周我都要教你一个新词。然后第二天我会问她，她就会说，哈？啊，算了吧！然后我们会过来喝咖啡。
Of the 12 homes on Annie's and Loretta's street, seven are owned by Hispanics, five by whites. It wasn't that the white homeowners who stayed were necessarily more tolerant than those who left. But some of the older folks have lived here all their lives and just didn't want to go, despite frequent appeals from realtors.
安妮和洛蕾塔这条街上的12户人家中，7户是拉美裔所有，5户是白人所有。并不是说留下的白人房主一定比离开的更宽容。但一些老住户住在这里一辈子了，就是不想走，尽管房地产商频繁地游说。
I remember getting something in the mail. Something about, if you're not comfortable where you live, if you fear for your safety, call this number. We'll sell your house.
我记得在邮件里收到过东西。关于如果你在住的地方不舒服，如果你担心自己的安全，拨打这个电话。我们会卖掉你的房子。
Oh, I called up that time. I called up the realtor. It was blockbusting.
哦，我当时打过那个电话。我给那个房地产经纪人打了电话。那是“街区破坏者”。
And you called the realtor? And what did you tell him?
你给房地产经纪人打了电话？你告诉他什么了？
I yelled. I said, you're doing the same thing as the blockbusters that did it on the West Side. Exactly the same thing. That stuff really-- to my mind, it's goofiness. You know, it's just somebody's out to make a buck, is what it is.
我大吼大叫。我说，你们做的事情和西区那些破坏街区的人一模一样。完全一样。那种东西真的……在我看来，是愚蠢的。你知道，有人只是为了赚钱而已。
When I first met Loretta, and I asked her about her Anglo neighbors, she volunteered a story that happened when she first moved in 12 years ago that clearly still bothers her. And it involves the other older white woman on the block, Nancy Chauvlin. Nancy is 70 and has lived in Cicero her entire life. Nancy has actually been friends with Annie since she was 18. In fact, Nancy found Annie her house.
当我第一次见到洛蕾塔，问起她的盎格鲁邻居时，她主动讲了一个她12年前刚搬进来时发生的故事，这显然仍然困扰着她。这涉及街区里的另一位老白人妇女，南希·肖夫林。南希70岁了，在西塞罗住了一辈子。南希事实上从18岁起就和安妮是朋友。事实上，南希帮安妮找到了她的房子。
Loretta remembers Nancy making comments to the effect that the quality of life in Cicero had declined since Mexican-Americans moved in, that there was more of a gang problem.
洛蕾塔记得南希曾发表过评论，认为西塞罗的生活质量自墨西哥裔美国人搬入以来已经下降，帮派问题更严重了。
And she would look at me like if it was my fault. And I would tell her, Nancy, we're not all the same. Just like in every race, there's good apples and bad apples. Do you see my kids in gangs? You know? But I don't think I ever really-- how can I put it-- made her understand.
她会看着我，好像那是我的错一样。我会告诉她，南希，我们并非都是一样的。就像每个种族一样，有好的苹果，也有坏的苹果。你看到我的孩子参与帮派了吗？你知道吗？但我认为我从来没真正——我该怎么说呢——让她理解。
So I went to visit Nancy, whose home is just three doors down from Loretta's. And I was kind of surprised by what I found.
所以我去拜访了南希，她的家距离洛蕾塔家只有三扇门。我对自己发现的情况感到有点惊讶。
I'm perfectly content here. And I have to say this. We see a lot more flowers getting planned around here than what we do with the old timers. We [? see, too, ?] they're planting gardens and fixing houses up. And a lot of the homes were let go by the older people. They weren't caused by the Hispanics moving in and destroying them. They were already unkempt buildings, and now the Hispanic people have come in, and many of them are really trying to fix things up.
我在这里非常满足。我不得不说这一点。我们看到这里的花比以前那些老住户规划得多了。他们种花园，修整房子。很多房子被老一辈人放着不管。这不是因为拉美裔搬进来破坏了它们，它们本来就是疏于打理的建筑，而现在拉美裔搬进来了，他们中的许多人确实在努力改善这些东西。
It turns out that Nancy helped Dave Boyle close down Mr. C's, the bikers' bar, going door-to-door with petitions, and she raised $600 from neighbors to rebuild Boyle's charred garage. For Nancy, like Annie, this was her home, and so it never occurred to her to move.
事实证明，南希帮助戴夫·博伊尔关掉了摩托车手酒吧“C先生酒吧”，挨家挨户征集签名，并从邻居那里筹集了600美元重建博伊尔烧焦的车库。对南希来说，像安妮一样，这是她的家，所以她从没想过要搬走。
Have you learned Spanish at all?
你学西班牙语了吗？
I took one course of Conversational Spanish at Morton College. Went back for the second course, they didn't have enough students, so they didn't have the course.
我在莫顿学院修了一门会话西班牙语课程。回去修第二门课程时，他们学生不够，所以没开课。
I used to go in one little store over here when I was taking the course. And a greeting in Spanish is "Hola!" Like "hello." Every day I'd go in the store, and before I walked in I thought, I got this right this time. And I go in and I go, "Halo!" And they just cracked up. No, that's wrong. It's like, here she comes again, you know?
我修那门课的时候，常去这里的一家小店。西班牙语的问候语是“Hola！”就像“你好”。每天我去店里，走进去之前我想，这次我肯定记对了。我走进去然后说，“Halo！”他们就笑坏了。不，那是错的。感觉就像，她又来了，你知道吗？
Have you acquired a taste for Mexican food at all?
你有喜欢上墨西哥食物吗？
Oh yeah, sure. I make my family stuff. My son-in-law is Mexican. I couldn't ask for a better son-in-law. And his family's wonderful.
噢，有的，当然。我给家人做那种吃的。我女婿是墨西哥人。我找不到比他更好的女婿了。他的家人也很好。
Do you speak any Spanish with him?
你和他讲西班牙语吗？
No, and he doesn't. And I told him, when the kids were little, I said Al, teach your kids Spanish! But he didn't want to do that.
不，他也不讲。我告诉过他，当孩子们还小的时候，我说艾尔，教你的孩子西班牙语！但他不想那样做。
Can I be real straight with you for a moment? It was curious to me, but I talked to Loretta--
我可以跟你直说吗？我很好奇，但我跟洛蕾塔谈过——
Finally I got up the courage to tell Nancy that Loretta thought she had some hostility towards Hispanics.
我终于鼓起勇气告诉南希，洛蕾塔认为她对拉美裔有些敌意。
I don't know why she'd even think that. The only thing I can think of is they have a dog, a chow dog, and when he was a puppy, they used to let him run wild all the time, and my daughter picked up twice, he almost got hit by a car. We heard the car screech, and there was Jenny picking the dog up. And she yelled at Loretta. And she said, keep the dog in! He's going to die. Because we had a chow and we loved it. But that's only incident I can think of.
我不知道她为什么会那么想。我能想到的唯一一件事是，她们有一只狗，一只松狮犬，当它是幼犬时，她们常让它四处乱跑，我女儿捡到过两次，它差点被车撞。我们听到了汽车刹车声，珍妮把狗捡起来。她对洛蕾塔大喊。她说，把狗看好！它会死的。因为我们养过一只松狮，我们很爱它。但这是我能想到的唯一事件。
Nancy doesn't recall making the kinds of remarks that Loretta complained about, though she does remember telling Loretta that there was a gang problem, and a lot of the Hispanic people don't keep tabs on their children.
南希不记得曾发表过洛蕾塔抱怨的那种言论，尽管她确实记得告诉过洛蕾塔有帮派问题，而且许多拉美裔人看管孩子不严。
This is where we get into the area where she and Loretta may never see eye-to-eye. Nancy doesn't see statements like these as offensive. She just thought they were statements of fact. Before the gang kids weren't here, now they were. And there were young kids hanging on the street corners late at night. From Loretta's point of view, it was clearly offensive.
这就是她和洛蕾塔可能永远无法达成共识的地方。南希并不觉得这些言论具有攻击性。她只是认为那是事实陈述。以前没有帮派孩子，现在有了。而且深夜有年轻人在街角游荡。从洛蕾塔的角度来看，这显然具有攻击性。
Though it's not as if Loretta is angry at Nancy. Wary is more like it. And maybe, they both said to me, when the weather warms, and they're hanging out in the backyard, they'll have a chance to talk. Or maybe they'll run into each other at Mary Queen of Heaven, the church on the corner.
虽然并不是说洛蕾塔对南希很生气。谨慎一点更像。也许，她们俩都告诉我，当天气转暖，她们在后院闲逛时，会有机会谈谈。或者也许她们会在拐角处的圣母玛利亚教堂相遇。
And this is Virginia Diaz--
这是弗吉尼亚·迪亚兹——
Which brings me back to Annie. One Sunday I attended Mary Queen of Heaven with her. We walked form the sacristy to the choir loft-- but not very far, but a 20 minute journey with Annie, who stops to say hello to everyone in our path.
这又让我想到了安妮。有一个周日我和她一起去圣母玛利亚教堂。我们从祭衣室走到唱诗班席位——虽然距离不远，但这是一段20分钟的旅程，因为安妮会停下来和路上的每一个人打招呼。
This is Armando Herrera, and he can't sing--
这是阿曼多·埃雷拉，他不会唱歌——
The best good-looking guy--
最帅的小伙子——
You can't sing.
你不会唱歌。
Well, you don't want me to, that's why.
好吧，你不想让我唱，那就是原因。
There's something remarkably easy about Annie, and it's what I think, in the end, so drew Loretta to her. Annie has for 30 years been a musical director at the church. The organ is located in the balcony, at the rear of the church. And from there, Annie, perched on a wooden piano bench, has watched this row change. On Sunday, she plays organ for the English mass at 8:30, and then for the Spanish mass that starts right after.
安妮身上有一种非常随和的感觉，这就是我认为最终吸引洛蕾塔的原因。安妮30年来一直是教堂的音乐总监。管风琴位于教堂后部的阳台上。从那里，安妮坐在木质钢琴凳上，看着这个街区发生变化。周日，她为8点半的英语弥撒弹奏管风琴，然后是紧随其后的西班牙语弥撒。
Annie, can you understand the sermon?
安妮，你能听懂布道吗？
I can get the gist of it. Want to know what the gist of it is? The basic gist of it is, I give you a new commandment. Love one another as I have loved you. That's the basis.
我能领会大意。想知道大意是什么吗？基本大意是，我给你们一条新诫命。我怎样爱你们，你们也要怎样互爱。这就是基础。
This church's congregation once was all white. On the morning I was there, at the English mass, there were maybe 150 worshippers spread out in the pews, all, as Annie joked, over the age of 90. At the Spanish mass, the pews filled with a thousand people, mostly families. Some couldn't find seats, and so stood along the walls of the church. Over the years, Annie has learned the Spanish hymns.
这个教堂的会众曾经全是白人。我去的那个早晨，在英语弥撒上，长椅上分散着大约150名礼拜者，正如安妮开玩笑说的，年纪都在90岁以上。在西班牙语弥撒中，长椅上坐满了上千人，大多是家庭。有些人找不到座位，就站在教堂墙边。多年来，安妮学会了西班牙语赞美诗。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
（唱西班牙语）
The changes in Cicero, as Annie will tell you, haven't made the town better or worse. They just are what they are. Annie now has her hair done by a Mexican-American, because quite simply, it's the closest hair salon. It's just around the corner.
正如安妮会告诉你的，西塞罗的变化并没有让城镇变得更好或更糟。它们就是那样。安妮现在让一个墨西哥裔美国人做发型，因为很简单，那是最近的理发店。就在拐角处。
The last time I saw her, she was talking about going to the traditional Quinceanera celebration for Loretta's younger daughter. It's being held at a place in Cicero called the European-American Hall. Some things change more slowly than others.
我最后一次见到她时，她在谈论去参加洛蕾塔小女儿传统的成人礼庆典。那是在西塞罗一个叫“欧美大厅”的地方举行的。有些事情改变得比其他事情慢。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
（唱西班牙语）
Well, our program was produced today but Blue Chevigny, Alex Kotlowitz, and me, with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Production help form Todd Bachmann and Annie Baxter.
我们的节目今天由布鲁·谢维尼、亚历克斯·科特洛维茨和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩。资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自托德·巴赫曼和安妮·巴克斯特。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（感谢辞）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《这个美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金赞助信息）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, you know, who used to visit Cicero and say things like,
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，你知道，他过去常去西塞罗说这样的话，
You won't be sorry for letting me in, Mr. Vettori. I'll shoot square with you.  I'll do anything you say. I ain't afraid of nothing.
让我进来你不会后悔的，维托里先生。我会和你公平交易。你让我做什么我就做什么。我什么都不怕。
No, he isn't. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
不，他并不怕。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《这个美国生活》，带来更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio international.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。